Did you realize that snake oil is the
number one most ignored superfood?
That's right. Wait till you hear what
real snake oil can do for your body. But
I first want to dive into the snake oil
concept that's been pushed out there for
over 100 years, especially in
relationship to snake oil salesmen. When
people think of that, they think of
health fraud. But let's do a little deep
dive into this topic because it has a
very interesting history. Back in the
1800s, there was a lot of people out
there selling all sorts of things in
them that weren't natural. Selling them
for arthritis and pain and digestive
issues and all sorts of things. And they
got a bad rap because some of them, not
all of them, had some ingredients that
weren't legit. Like for example, this
gentleman here, Clark Stanley, he was
selling snake oil for arthritis. But
then when the government tested his
snake oil, they found there was no snake
oil in there. And so he got in trouble
and his fine was I think back then it
was $20. Nowadays it'd probably be about
600 bucks. So he got a slap on the
wrist. He's like the poster child of the
snake oil salesperson and it got branded
to anything natural at the time because
right about that time there was a bit of
competition between this new drug
industry and natural remedies, herbs,
etc. There was a shift towards more new
pharmaceutical drugs. But in reality,
back then, snake oil was shipped from
China. For the Chinese that were working
on the railroad all day long, they had
to use some remedy that was really good
for arthritis and pain. And that's what
they used back then. But of course, some
people that sold it didn't really have
the legitimate snake oil. And that snake
oil back then they used it was a very
specific Chinese water snake. It wasn't
an American rattlesnake that did not
have the same amount of omega-3s. So in
1906 was the birth of the pure food and
drug act and they were going after like
um misbranding and also adulteration of
foods. Uh definitely sold across state
lines and that itself is has an
interesting history because there was a
gentleman that was in charge that had
integrity but they very quickly booted
him out because his battle back then was
fighting adulterated food like highly
refined wheat. And fast forward to
present time, we have a lot of foods
that are adulterated, right? Cheaper
versions of food. We have cheaper
versions of sugar cane with high
fructose corn syrup and beet sugar. And
then you have the seed oils which
replace the the healthier fats, the
saturated fats, as well as the olive
oil. Now, the FDA actually started at
least for a very short period of time to
be very uh non-corrupted. But then, of
course, look at what happened. If we
really analyze what a snake oil
salesperson is, it is some person or
group that is committing health fraud.
Their ingredients are dangerous. They're
counterfeit. They're falsely marketed as
a cure. They're giving false claims.
It's pseudocience.
They have shills. Like for example, back
in the day when they had these uh snake
oil salespeople, they usually had
someone in the crowd who was a shill,
who was basically a plant, someone that
was supporting this claim, and they
would maybe raise their hand and said,
"Hey, I tried it. It's worked great. You
guys should try it, too. I wonder if
this is still going on to some degree."
And as I was looking at it, I'm like,
it's definitely going on nowadays. Can
you actually buy a scientist to support
your drug? The answer is yes. Big Pharma
has been involved in criminal fraud
cases and I'm talking about in the tune
of a hundred billion dollar settlement
fees. The organizations that took over
from the initial uh snake oil
salespeople are basically just replace
them, but they're much bigger companies
now. In one case, $150 million lawsuit
with another $600 million uh civil uh
penalties. Many drugs are considered
safe and effective and then all of a
sudden they're found to be severely
dangerous like Vio. Vio was considered
to be safe until they found out like
60,000 people died and so they had to
take it off the market. How did that
happen? Well, obviously there's fraud,
there's corruption, there's very little
transparency in the actual data of these
research studies. Just think about
psychiatric diagnosises, right? There
are like thousands of different things
for normal behaviors. They literally
vote on what this disease is. There's no
objective testing. It's all let's vote
on this disease and they manufacture
diseases. Currently, there's 17,000
different diseases. Back in 1900, there
was only like 200. So, in other words,
there's been a lot of manufacturing
diseases purely to just it's a cash cow.
And then what about the SSRI, right?
Those drugs for depression and anxiety,
billions of dollars. Recently, they
found out that this whole chemical
imbalance theory was never proven. It's
not true. All of these SSRIs based on
this false claim that it can help
balance your chemistry was never true.
To me, that is snake oil on steroids,
especially since it barely works better
than the placebo and but it causes
massive, massive harm to that patient
who takes it. We have this situation
where we have exaggerated benefits and
minimize side effects. We have
situations where big pharma is not even
liable if they get sued with vaccines,
for example. Then you also have a
situation where you can buy insulin in
another country for a fraction of the
money that you can buy it in the US. So
there's just a lot of uh financial
manipulation as well in the area of
drugs. From my viewpoint, big pharma is
snake oil 2.0. We have now legalized
snake oil salespeople who are FDA
approved that can patent a remedy and
then have the FDA police that patent.
That's what they do. Incredible. Nowhere
out there can someone have a patent and
have another organization like the FDA
protect the drug companies from anyone
infringing on their patents. I mean,
it's just mind-blowing. You have many of
the expert panels within the health
administration, the government uh have
massive conflicts of interest. To me,
that's not science. That's not
legitimate. That falls in this category
right here simply because there's money
involved. And then what about the mental
health screenings in schools? I mean,
it's like a recruitment funnel for the
psychiatrist. I mean, that is going on
right now. Hopefully, we'll be able to
stop it. So, please explain to me in the
comments how different this modern-day
snake oil is different from in the past.
Very, very similar operation. It's just
a lot bigger. And somehow the whole
thing has been inverted
where natural remedies now, even
legitimately studied natural remedies
are considered snake oil. I mean, it's
beyond me. Let's get into real snake oil
and what are the some of the benefits of
it. What's interesting about snake oil,
it's one of the richest sources of
omega-3, specifically this EPA. Omega-3
fatty acids uh are composed of uh mainly
two things. DHA, which is kind of a
structural fat for your brain, and it's
really good to repair brain cells and
cognitive function. But then you have
this other omega-3 called EPA. Very
different different function. Snake oil
is super high in EPA more than fish oil,
more than salmon oil, more than a lot of
other foods. So now the question is what
does EPA really do? If we take a drug or
like an anti-inflammatory, what that's
going to do, it's going to block an
enzyme. But that's not what this does.
This literally changes the
pro-inflammatory factors to more
anti-inflammatory
factors. It changes the whole ecosystem.
And when you do that, you don't get the
side effects from the drug. This EPA is
a very potent anti-inflammatory
compound. anything involving
inflammation, whether it's arthritis,
berscitis, tendinitis, autoimmune. They
also found that it has some pretty
potent effects on depression. So, it's
even considered like a natural
anti-depressant.
It's also been found to decrease the
risk of cardiovascular
heart attacks by 25%. It also can help
decrease the risk of fibrosis. This is
scar tissue because when you have
inflammation that's unregulated, it can
then turn into scar tissue as the body
is trying to heal from the inflammation.
So this EPA can actually reduce the risk
of fibrosis in the liver, in the heart,
anywhere, even in the brain. Also, it's
been found that EPA increases insulin
sensitivity. So, it's going to make your
blood sugars work better. Great for
diabetics. There's been some really cool
effects on decreasing the risk of
autoimmunity. And even if someone has an
autoimmune disease, improving it. Why?
Because the biggest part of an
autoimmune problem is inflammation. And
if you're going to do anything for that
condition, reducing inflammation would
be the number one thing you want to do.
They even found that it actually could
decrease tumors because it improves the
regulation of the immune system, which
is just fascinating. And of course, big
pharma tried to patent this EPA. They
couldn't do that. So, they came out with
a compound and they're using it now for
arthritis and I think decreasing
triglycerides. One last point about
snake oil. You can use this topically.
You can rub it on a joint. It can
actually help reduce inflammation
without even taking it orally, which is
pretty wild. So, I hope that shifted
your viewpoint on real snake oil. If you
have not seen my video on the
anti-inflammatory foods that you should
be eating, you should check it out. I
put it up right here.